[Musique]
la diminution progressive de l'oxygène
dans les eaux profondes l'estuaire et du
golfe du saint-laurent préoccupe de plus
en plus les chercheurs les données de
2021 marque à nouveau creux inquiéta
le fleuve saint-laurent ne nous habite
on y joue haut niveau pour prendre l'air
c'est le poumon de l'économie du
tourisme
mais paradoxalement tout au fond ils
étouffent par manque d'oxygène
d'une année à l'autre les missions
scientifiques se succèdent et mesure la
teneur en oxygène dissous dans les eaux
du saint-laurent où les enfants semblent
ouailles haddock nouvelles comme
d'habitude en 2021 les chercheurs de
l'institut des sciences de la mer ont
plongé leurs instruments de mesure au
fond de l'eau dans l'estuaire et le
golfe mais surprise
l'instrument descend tranquillement dans
la colonne d'eau puis petit à petit on
voit les concentration diminuée diminué
diminue 10.20 même les collègues et moi
on était vraiment surpris de voir que
savait autant diminué alors c'était un
peu la consternation puis un peu on sait
il ya eu un temps d'arrêt ok qu'est ce
qu'on fait sur deux sites en particulier
au large de rimouski les niveaux
d'oxygène sont consterne c'est autour de
10% de saturation d'oxygène dans l'eau
c'est des taux qui sont très très bonnes
dans les années 30 ce niveau se situait
autour de 50% puis graduellement il a
chuté de moitié pour se stabiliser
autour de 20 à 25% milieu des années 80
avant de plonger ces derniers temps à
des valeurs encore plus faible
moi quand j'ai vu ces données là ou là
j'ai pleuré sa mort vraiment perturbé
[Musique]
alfonso mucci a passé sa vie à étudier
le fleuve saint laurent ce qui les
inquiète c'est que la zone qu'ils
considèrent en hypoxie sévère en deçà de
20 % d'oxygène dissous s'est élargi
en 2002 on avait répertorié environ 1300
kilomètres carrés entre est commun et un
peu à l'est de rimouski ensuite c'était
attendu à pointe dément cette île et des
tout dernièrement en octobre la zone
hypoxique s'étendaient le long du 49e
parallèle donc bien dans le golfe
l'oxygène ne manquent pas partout dans
le saint-laurent seulement dans la
couche d'eau tout au fond à 150 mètres
et plus
denis gilbert suit depuis longtemps la
transformation des courants océaniques
qui transporte l'oxygène dans le fond du
saint laurent
les autres dans le fond du saint-laurent
ne nous arrive pas de morial ou de
québec les hawks ont dans le fond de
l'estuaire au large de rimouski au large
des escoumes 1 et nous proviennent de
l'atlantique nord
l'oxygène contenu dans ces eaux provient
surtout des eaux froides et profondes du
courant du labrador
une partie de ces eaux contourne les
grands bancs terre-neuve pour entrer
dans le chenal laurentien will se
mélange aux eaux du gulf stream plus
chaudes et plus pauvres en oxygène
c'est au même de 6 à 7 ans pour
parcourir la distance entre l'embouchure
du chenal laurentien et tadoussac
dans les années 30 il y avait
pratiquement le trois-quarts de la
composition de la masse d'eau dans les
eaux profondes qui étaient des os de
type courant du labrador puis à peu près
le quart qui étaient des eaux du type on
veut dire golf stream ou subtropicales
alors que à partir des années 2000 la
proportion était déjà rendu à peu près
moitié moitié et les plus récents
modèles numériques suggère que cela ira
en s'amplifiant le bleu représente ici
les eaux riches en oxygène du courant du
labrador
quand la part du co2 dans l'atmosphère
passe du simple au double et que le
climat se réchauffe comme c'est la
tendance actuelle une moindre portion du
courant du labrador atteint le saint
laurent
la great hall c'est donc là que moins de
dos du courant aux radars qui arrive au
bout de la ligne à contourner la queue d
g al terre-neuve et puis ça rame vers
l'embouchure du chenal laurentien pour
les espèces qui vivent dans le fond du
fleuve moins d'oxygène ça veut dire
moins d'énergie
alors si l'animal doit travailler pour
gagner sa vie aller chercher de la
nourriture éviter les prédateurs et sur
tout digéré ce qu'ils marchent
s'apprendre l'oxygène c'est la situation
continue d'empirer on pourrait en
arriver à une valeur d'oxygène pour
cette espèce là où l'animal n'est plus
capable de digérer n'est plus capable de
nager et finalement ça veut dire qu'on a
atteint le seuil létal
et le seuil de tolérance des espèces à
la diminution de l'oxygène dissous
varient évidemment il ya les athlètes
puis il ya les autres
dans ces bassins de recherche à
mont-joli denis chabot mesure ces seuils
de tolérance chez différentes espèces
selon nos travaux de laboratoire la
morue est une espèce un peu plus
sensible que le flétan du groenland et
la crevette et dans le code la morue le
chenal profond est devenu tellement
hypoxique que c'est un endroit où la
morue ne pourrait pas habiter à nouveau
même si le stock était abondant
s'ajoute à la diminution de l'oxygène
dissous dans les eaux profondes du
fleuve la hausse des températures de
l'eau à 300 mètres de profondeur la
température de l'eau dans l'estuaire est
passé de 4,26 à 6,08 de grille en 50 ans
quand on monte à température un petit
peu les dépenses énergétiques des
animaux augmente
en moyen d'une crevette femelles à 5
degrés peut tolérer jusqu'à 16% de
saturation à 8 degrés ce qui est quand
même pas tellement plus chaud ça devient
22% de saturation en oxygène
donc ça a rendu l'animal plus sont ses
mots l'autre phénomène qui préoccupe les
chercheurs c'est le fait que les
bactéries puissent utiliser d'autres
occident pour dégrader la matière
organique en suspension et dans les
sédiments les bactéries vont utiliser le
l'occident qui est le plus efficace pour
oxyder cette matière organique et
l'occident le plus efficace c'est
l'oxygène mais lorsque la concentration
en oxygène va donner
faible ou absente ils vont utiliser
d'eau occident qui leur sont disponibles
donc les nitrates
une fois les nitrates utilisés les
bactéries vont se tourner vers les
oxydes de fer et de manganèse en ce
moment ces oxydes served éponge il
absorbe les métaux lourds du moins
jusqu'à ce que les bactéries des utilise
donc quand ils vont réduire ces oxydes
les oxydes vont relargué leur charge de
métaux absorbé dans la colonne d'eau
donc on va voir une augmentation en
concentration de métaux lourds dans la
colonne d'eau ya un changement
fondamental vraiment important dans
notre écosystème profond du saint
laurent
parmi les questions qui restent en
suspens on se demande jusqu'à quel point
les espèces pourront migrer dans les
eaux plus oxygéné ou si la vie dans le
fond du fleuve fait disparaître
graduellement
au fur et à mesure que ton oxygène best
eu perte de biodiversité puis moi je
m'attends en fait avoir avant que je
sois mort je m'attends à voir de l'âne
occident et bond en eau profonde saunal
dans la nuque si ça ça veut dire zéro
pour ça les chercheurs on peut juste le
dire mais on n'a pas beaucoup de
solutions qu'on est capable de
comprendre mais qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire
c'est de là que vient notre désarroi je
pense
ce qui se passe au fond du saint-laurent
loin de nos yeux tout en fera surface on
réalisera alors à quel point le
réchauffement planétaire nous a
rattrapés sans qu'on y prenne garde